je vous en donne la primeur c'est une
chanson qui a été écrite par Jean-Loup
Dabadie et que Roland Vincent a mis en
musique ça s'appelle l'école
donc la mémoire
ça n'était pas celle du grand monde mais
c'était mon école
le matin bien avant le jour on entendait
sonner la cloche et dans un grand prix
de galoche l'entrée dans la cour
mais grand copains c'était casa
comment déjà ce pitre il y avait un chat
dans son cartable son père était arbitre
on s'en revenait dans le tramway ont
limité monsieur Fayolle l'ennemi était
au panda
mais l'enfant se passait
son passé les feuilles des Marronniers
ils sont enroulés lorsque j'avais des
coeur
S se sont là quand on a fait les draps
on est des slips c'est là on mange de
son tablier
une fois j'avais eu un plumier j'avais
été presque premier et sur le couvercle
vernis avec Paris la nuit
on voyageait en audité les forêts
d'Alsace à la Chine et dans les poches
de nos pèlerins
mais le plus beau c'était quand même le
mardi quand on a des destin
on croise les filles en promenade en
leur disait j'étais mort alors le soir
pendant l'étude on se prenait pour de
grandir monsieur Fayol fumait sa fille
le nerf de solitude
ou sans passer les feuilles
ils sont en bélancent
on essuyait cela on mange de son papier
il est parti l'autre jeudi fumer sa
fille au Paradis ma mère l'avait revu
longtemps il n'avait pas d'enfant
au sable noir monsieur Fayol ou dessiner
le cours du Rhône ça n'était pas celle
du grand mot
mais c'était mon école
en ce temps-là
on mange descends tablier